In her book, The Smart Woman's Guide to Breast Cancer, Dr. Jennifer Simmons mentions oxycodone
as possibly contributing to breast cancer.
What are your thoughts on this?
What might an alternative be?
Dr. Jennifer Simmons used to be a breast surgeon for, I think, 19 years before she just hung
up the towel and went into doing more alternative things.
I have interviewed her several times on my podcast.
You can see those interviews on our feed and our blog posts in your membership.
She's interviewed me on her podcast, so we've become friends over the years and it would
be not just oxycodone, it's all sorts of medications that contribute to all sorts of cancers and
how do they contribute?
Because medications have toxic side effects and they can contribute to not only blocking
and damaging liver detox pathways, so you're not going to detox other toxins that you're
exposed to as well.
And thereby, the more toxins that you can't get rid of, the more toxins you will hold.
And thereby, it could be causes of cancer and causes of inability to help deal with cancer.
But different drugs have side effects that can block tuber suppressor genes and all sorts
of things.
Now, I understand that if you have cold morbidities and why would a person take oxycodone because
they're pained, so if they have serious pain issues and they're on medications for that
and then the side effects could be worse than the pain per se, and it's really hard to
determine whether B and oxycodone was a cause of the cancer, but it certainly isn't helping.
Is there an alternative to oxycodone?
Well, it's hard to find a natural alternative to pain medication because how strong those medications
are in blocky, nerve impulses, there's nothing naturally that's going to do quite the same.
So if a person has general pain and inflammation, the first thing you think of is the flavonoids,
the curcumin, high-dose curcumin, high-dose resveratrol, Boswellia, stiggy, dental, corset,
and etc., but that's not going to cut real serious pain.
Well, is there other natural things that you could do to help with pain?
Well, you could think of white willow bark and different things like that, but again, that's
not going to deal with real serious pain.
From a natural perspective, probably you're looking at something like in the THC realm
to help cut pain, but that's not without side effects either, because you'd feel very loopy
and etc., but we've had a number of people that just did not want to go with the medical
pain-killing apparatus that's out there, and they would go with THC, don't.
This day at age, it's pretty easy to get THC just about every state that's legal in it.
If you go to the different little THC stores out there, and you explain to them what you
have going on, you have pain from cancer, they would be able to help you to get a dosage
that would be beneficial, but that's probably from a natural pain-reducing standpoint, THC,
which is the active form of the marijuana plant, is going to be your best bet, I would
say.
I know years past, there's been information about CBD as a benefit for paid, and we did
everything under the sun trying to use that for patients, and quite honestly, it's just
not as, as that's not effective enough with serious pain, THC has been effective, but it's
done without side effects again.